I'm not here to traumatize
any of you that already finished HSC.
Please just be free.
But for my week 4 victims,
I'm still here.
These are all my last minute tips for PHP tomorrow.
Even if you know all the syllabus content,
every single dot point inside out,
if you don't address the Nessa verb,
you cannot pull those high marks during the exam.
It's really easy to focus on the content and
your examples that you end up neglecting the task worth.
The best way to
avoid this is to just memorize some judgement
terminology,
force specific verbs.
I recommend memorizing some of this judgement based
vocab for those high ordinous
verbs that come up in 8 markers and 12 markers
but use this terminology and link back to it in
your response to completely answer the question.
Lot of questions are gonna
ask you guys to include examples
and it's so important that those are specific,
whether that's performance,
sport or initiative based.
So go through your syllabus and think to yourself,
what examples would I use for different dot points?
Stats and trends are really gonna support
and enhance your responses
so it's good to have some ready.
These are some that you can memorize for call 1
Aboriginal Torres,
Strait Islander,
People's Healthy Equities.
Remember that a lot of the questions are based off
the syllable stop point
so you need to answer it with the dashes under.
So if they ask you to explain
The stages of school acquisition.
For example,
you need 1 dash per paragraph
or cognitive,
associative
and autonomous.